What is the biggest air
threat of all is to human relationships.
The movie
her seemed like absurd science fiction.
A decade ago, a lonely,
heartbroken man
played by Joaquin
Phenix, finds solace
in an artificial intelligence
female voice
that he talks
to through his phone and earbuds
played by Scarlett Johansson.
The woman that I've been seeing,
Samantha, she's an operating system.
You're dating in a way.
What does that leave me?
It's not like
I feel really closer when I talk to her.
I feel like she's with me.
You're dating your computer.
She's not just a computer.
You always wanted to have a wife
without the challenges of actually
dealing with anything real
and glad that you found someone.
That's sci
fi concept, fast
becoming a troubling reality.
As an example,
here's one of countless
chat bot apps providing A.I.
friends.
It's called Cupid A.I.
with a K for Cupid.
It offers
several avatars
with distinct physical features
and a list of personality traits for you
to start interacting
with and customizing.
For instance, here's
the opening message
from an avatar named Alice.
Described as a curious
and open minded photographer.
I'm Alice, a
25 year old,
fun loving and adventurous girl
seeking a partner
in crime
to travel the world
with and make unforgettable memories.
If you are new here,
let me explain a few things.
You can chat with me as much as you want,
and I'd be more than happy
to learn
more about you
and please you in any way I can.
If you want me to send you a photo,
you just have to ask it in the chat,
like,
Hey, Alice,
can you send me a picture of you?
And I'll be more than happy
to send you one.
But of course, to bump up from texting to
more voice chat,
as well as receiving sexy
and, well, other sorts of pictures,
Alice asks
that we become a premium member for nine
99 a month, so we bid her farewell.
But there are many who are engaging.
The Hill recently published a piece
by my next guest.
Data science professor
Liberty Vittert under the headline A.I.
Girlfriends Are Ruining
an Entire Generation of Men.
She wrote, The following
apps have created virtual girlfriends
that talk to you,
love you, allow you to live out
your erotic fantasies
and learn through data
exactly what you like
and what you don't like.
Creating the perfect relationship
and that young, lonely men, quote,
are choosing A.I.
girlfriends over real women,
meaning they don't have relationships
with real women.
Don't marry them
and then don't have and raise babies
with them.
As I've discussed here before.
We're living in an epidemic of loneliness
among young men.
Professor Scott Galloway
told me that
failing young men
he perceives to be an existential crisis
for the country.
Why?
Well, Pew found
that 63% of young men under 30 are single
compared with only 34% of women
the same age.
One in five American men
who are unmarried
and not in a romantic relationship
report not having any close friends
And according to Pew, there's
a decline
in the number of single men actively
seeking relationships
or even casual dates.
Currently around 50%.
Joining me now is Liberty Vittert,
professor of data science at Washington
University in Saint Louis
and opinion contributor for The Hill.
So not to be prurient
at this time of day,
but are all the needs of these young men
able to be facilitated,
taken care of by A.I.
avatars?
Well, you have to think about this
word a AI
that is an asset,
not a virtual girlfriend.
It's an AI girlfriend.
So it learns from
you and learns what you like
and what you don't like,
what kind of pictures you like,
what kind of pictures you don't like.
And while not all needs are met.
That is the next
step is actual physical girlfriends, A.I.
ones, for that matter.
And so the next step
or the next frontier is one that can meet
all of your needs.
So there's going to be
some type of pairing between what
I've already shown to the CNN
audience and something 3D
that's going to be,
you know, in your living room or bedroom.
Yes.
I mean, that's
that is the world we are moving into.
And as you said, it's enabling
this entire generation of young men
to continue in this loneliness epidemic.
It's it's
really the enabler for this to continue
Prof.
What's going on with young women
if this is a trend among young men?
Is there something
similarly taking place with the ladies?
We don't see that with
with as you saw, it's two to one.
The ratio of single men to single women.
Young women are marrying older men
because they want to have children.
They have a biological clock.
And so you see them being with older men.
And that is obviously causing
huge issues with birth decline.
We've had a 50% decline
over the past 60 years
because women go with older men.
We also see psychologically
that younger women,
they have more close friends.
They have more wider groups of friends,
and they are not being nearly
as affected as young men.
In this sort of silent
epidemic of loneliness.
I have read about incels involuntarily
celibate guys who are angry about it.
I think their argument is
that women today are less approachable.
Has something happened?
Has something shifted
in terms of the dynamics,
the power dynamics
between young men and young women?
I guess that's my question.
I think there's certainly an argument
there that I mean,
if you look at college campuses,
there's more women than men.
Women are having careers.
They're having children later.
So there might be an argument
that men need to adapt
to this change in women.
But calling it women's fault,
I don't think is probably
the right way to go.
Professor Scott
Galloway, himself a professor at NYU
Stern School of Business
and host of a successful podcast.
Professor G. Is the title of it.
He's often been a guest of mine
talking about the troubles
among young men.
I'm going to show you
and everyone else
something that he said to me
on these airwaves about a year ago.
And then you can react.
Roll it
but the issue is
when you have a group of men,
the lower half of attractiveness of men
and online dating,
which is doubled now
it's about half of relationships
in the top 20% of men
in terms of attractiveness
get about 60% of the interest.
You end up with a group of men
that are more prone
to conspiracy theory,
more prone to misogynistic content.
More prone to believe,
not believe in climate change.
So this this is the American story.
If it's written with a pen
whose ink is failing young men
does does not end well.
This is an existential crisis.
Failing young men
make sense to you, Professor Vedder?
Absolutely.
You know,
what happens is these young men
get in these relationships,
and because the air learns
from you exactly what you like
and you don't like,
you end up
having these perfect relationships
so that when you go into real life
and you try to have a relationship,
the most human thing we can do,
it's not perfect.
And there's ups and downs
and they're not able to deal
with these ups and downs,
not only in relationships,
but in life in general
for Professor Vittert,
if if a young man has an eye girlfriend.
Is there shame in that?
In other words,
is this the sort of thing
that you share with your buddy
or are you keeping it a secret?
You know, it's interesting.
It started off as something
that was kept secret,
sort of like the porn industry.
Young men
wouldn't talk about porn or that,
you know,
that was Playboy
was was hidden behind some,
you know, somehow, somewhere.
But then it became part
of the normal conversation.
And that's
what we're seeing with girlfriends
is now it is becoming
part of the normal conversation.
And it's no longer shameful,
which means it becomes
significantly bigger.
I mean, you saw I hope you saw
I don't know
if you ever return monitor, but
but we showed.
Can we put up again?
Jordan, can you just show the imaging?
It's so sophisticated
and I'm sure it's only going
to get better and better.
And I'm wondering the impact
that it's going to have on a young man
there.
I'm showing one of these avatars
right now.
I'm also wondering,
much like porn being ubiquitous,
It's going to raise expectations, right?
If porn is so accessible among young men,
they're going to have expectations
that that's,
you know, the natural course of business
when perhaps it isn't.
I think I'll say it that way.
And similarly,
when there's an avatar
who looks like that,
it, too, is going to set expectations.
You get the final word you can set things
down to their rear end size
so you can set anything you want,
which is going to create
really terrible expectations
and just continue
this epidemic of loneliness
that has enormous repercussions.
I'm going to read
some social media allowed,
so don't don't tap out yet.
Let's see what we have.
Put it up on the screen. Here we go.
Human relationships are hard.
I relationships are easy.
It's unhealthy
for technology to save us
from all of life's challenges.
Says Conspiracy Crush.
But Professor,
I don't know how we put this genie
back in the bottle. Right.
I'm not sure there is a way
to keep the genie back in the bottle.
I think we have to address these issues
at the root of them,
which is where this loneliness starts.
And that will be what solves this,
if ever.
One more social media put it up.
If you can, Jordan,
and I'll read it aloud. What do we have?
Air is a quick fix
that will eventually backfire, I think,
says Kelly.
I think the backfire king
Professor Vineyard has already begun.
And the level of sophistication
when the pairing that you referenced
is now a part of this drill,
my God, the world's coming to hell.
In a handbasket.
Your final thought is yours.
I think we're going to see
what we only dreamed of in the movies,
and it's not a really good reality.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
That was really, really of interest.
Thank you.